Oh Duke race yes we have Maurice Ashley
with our winner well we are here for the
prize-giving as world champion magnus
carlsen has won this event in dominating
fashion we have him with us as well as
lat go Klarich who is the organizer of
this beautiful event slotko I know you
have some hardware for Magnus why don't
you present it to him thank you thank
you
thank you there we have it a fantastic
trophy spanning the globe as the
Grantchester spans the globe as well
Magnus this was a great event for you
contextualize what it felt like playing
here first of all in Zagreb in Croatian
it's it's been a wonderful event it's
great to be here in in summer with the
vibe and with so many so many chess fans
it's really the first time that I'm
playing a grown-up tournaments in
Croatia or former Yugoslavia for for
that matter and I've always heard about
the chess culture and I have to say that
it's delivered in every way they were
clapping at the beginning and the end
even all the games no matter what the
result yeah and today as well after my
game finished there there was some
applause and I really appreciated that
and I would like to thank all the fans
for for coming here and giving us
players such wonderful support your
feeling about this event you've won a
lot of events this year all of them
you've played in what is this place in
any kind of special way for me it's it's
huge it's it's the first time basically
that I've played an event like this 12
players all absolute elite and I really
didn't know what what to expect I've
been playing a lot recently I felt a bit
spent towards the end of Norway chess
but it's it's been a it's been a dream
especially the second half has come so
well and now I'm just happy to to
be be done and to be very very satisfied
for for a month before I get going again
I was gonna say that you've won so many
events in a row do you feel like you
want to go play again a lot of them are
gonna play in Riga you're saying give me
a month off yeah
part of me is obviously itching to play
again but I'm I'm pretty tired at this
point and I think a month of this kana
is gonna be wonderful it's not too
little but it's it's just about enough
to to get a rest but still keep keep
that hunger
congratulations Magnus wonderful result
we look forward to seeing you in a month
thank you very much
world champion Magnus Carlsen the winner
of his eighth straight event a fantastic
finish for the world number one Thank
You Maurice and I'm thinking